Hey, Vsauce. Michael here. And what do you
say we get outta here...to space and into
an orbit. That way we could just float around
and be free from the influence of gravity.
Except not really.
Astronauts orbiting around the Earth experience
pretty much the same gravitational pull that
you and I are feeling right now. The major
difference is that those astronauts are falling,
constantly, towards Earth, but their angular
velocity is so large that they're falling just
as fast as Earth curves away from them. Now,
of course, this is nothing New...ton's Cannon
hasn't already taught us.
Gravity makes stuff fall and, in particular,
Newton realized that it makes objects accelerate
towards the Earth the same amount independently
of how fast they're moving horizontally. That's
called relativity. And, of course, orbiting
is just falling, but falling where you move
horizontally fast enough that the earth falls
away faster. In order to successfully fall
and miss the Earth, unless you dug a tunnel,
you need to be travelling at over 17,000 mph
or 8 km every second. So, you'd probably
incinerate from friction with the air, well
before you had a chance to enjoy the trip.
Of course, Newton's thought experiment involved
the Earth, but on something smaller, like
the Moon, the cannon wouldn't have to throw
its projectile nearly as fast for it to complete
an orbit. In fact, if you had a powerful enough
gun on the Moon and you fired that gun at
the horizon and then waited a little bit,
you could get hit in the back of the head
by the same bullet.
Henry calculated that the bullet would have
to travel about 1,600 m/s, which is exactly
how fast the Paris gun fires.
Now, that's a powerful gun, it's no squirt
gun. But if you had a squirt gun, out there
in space, and you fired a stream of water
at the Sun, how much water would it take to
put out the Sun? I mean, in general, putting
water on something hot would cause that something
hot to lose some heat, especially since the
water will be frozen because it's out there
in space. But, here's the issue. The Sun is
not a big ball of hydrogen on fire. Instead,
the Sun is powered by fusion.
Fusion of Hydrogen nuclei, which is kind of
like the chemical bonds between the Hydrogen
and Oxygen that make up water, except on a
much smaller and much more powerful scale.
Now, before I get tackled by nuclear physicists
from one side, and chemists from the other,
let me explain.
A bond of any sort, whether between planets,
molecules, atoms, nuclei or quarks is just
a happenstance where two or more particles
together have a lower total energy than when
they were apart. Like if you get married
and your taxes go down. So, when you form
a bond, that extra energy that the two solitary
particles had is released, and because of
a little relation we called "E=mc²," this
actually means that the mass of the pair goes
down a little bit too.
For example, every fusion reactions turns
a little bit of Hydrogenous mass into light.
Sunlight, for example, amounts to a loss of
100 quadrillion kg each year. That's the equivalent
of a medium sized asteroid. But stars have
a lot of mass and the more massive a star
is, the hotter it burns. And adding a bunch
of water to the Sun would only cause it to
be more massive, so it would burn brighter,
not go out. Of course, it would also burn
faster, which means that its life would be shorter.
For instance, if you were to add 20 solar
masses of water to the Sun, you would decrease
its life expectancy from the current 5 billion
years to only a few hundred million more years.
But there's a faster way to put out the Sun.
Take that water, or whatever material you
want, and shoot it into the Sun in a way that
causes everything to get spread out and scattered,
so that there's no longer the critical density
needed for fusion to occur. Now, no matter
which avenue of putting out the Sun you pick,
both would be a disaster. Literally, disaster.
From "Dis," meaning "against," and "aster"
meaning star, you would have literally turned
our own star against us.
If you were somehow able to avoid that disaster
by magically appearing in inter-galactic space,
here's a fun experiment to try. Take out your
gun and fire a bullet. That bullet will be
forever alone.
That's because the universe is expanding,
and if you were a few megaparsec's away from
the nearest galactic cluster, on average those
galaxies would be 200 km father away from
you every passing second. In space terms,
200 km per second is pretty slow. It's barely
as fast as the solar system orbits the center
of the Milky Way. And stars closer to the
center of the galaxy can orbit 10 times faster.
But a measly bullet travels only a few km
every second and would have no chance of reaching
the receding galaxies, ever.
It makes you realize how tiny we are compared
to the scale of the universe. But it also
makes you realize how close together we all
are here on Earth. Of course, to get from
one side of the Earth to the other, you have
to fly over half the sphere.
So, what if instead there was a tunnel through
the Earth? Let's jump over to my channel,
Minute Physics, to see what happens.
Click here and I'll see you on the other side.
Oh, and as always,
thanks for watching.